[Música]
bom dia meu nome é felipe caffé nec e já
falarei sobre impressora 3d
eu aposto que a impressora 3d têm mais
utilidade do que você imagina impressão
3d é um processo usado para criar um
objeto tridimensional com camadas de
material em 1981
o japonês que deu cantando inventou dois
métodos de fabricação tridimensional com
o plástico em 1984 tinha que o
desenvolveu e patenteou a impressora 3d
como impressora 3d é possível fazer
próteses para os humanos sapatos roupas
brinquedos e utensílios domésticos
instrumentos musicais casas e armas seja
parou pra pensar que não vai mais
precisar ir ao shopping para comprar
essas coisas
hoje com 32 mil reais se compra uma
impressora que o plástico para imprimir
com um software você poderá imprimir só
rouba o desenho dos jetsons criada pelo
estúdio ana bárbara 55 anos atrás
projetavam ano de 2062 e hoje uma parte
da ficção virou realidade
bom dia hoje que vem para o café suco de
laranja ovos bacon torrada com marmelada
e café
como sequer jogos enquanto os ovos
cuidando do seu colesterol em george de
[Música]
algumas curiosidades planta vai produzir
ponte e impressora 3d menina de 9 anos
cria prótese para seu professor o
antebraço com dedos articulados algumas
fábricas permitiram impressão de peças
de reposição de aparelhos eletrônicos e
estela é o nome da primeira impressora
3d compacta do brasil a nossa levou uma
impressora 3d para espaços para produzir
ferramentas e peças de reposição ea
matéria prima usada é o plástico verde
da cana de açúcar feito por uma empresa
brasileira a braskem agora passarei um
vídeo de uma impressora 3d em ação e
tempo real que leva para imprimir a 15
minutos
[Música]
o que você faria se tivesse uma
impressora 3d
se eu tivesse uma impressora 3d eu
queria próteses para pessoas e animais
necessitados que não tem um braço ou uma
perna por exemplo
se todo mundo tivesse essa mesma idéia
inteligente poderia ser ajudada e
viveria muito melhor
acho que com o tempo o custo da
impressora 3d vai diminuir e permitir
que as pessoas tenham acesso mais rápido
às suas coisas e quem sabe
valorizem - as coisas e mais as pessoas
e aí pessoal agora para um futuro
tecnológico mais fácil vamos fazer mais
humano
obrigado pela sua atenção